TO MOTHER TERESA AND DOORKNOBS,
DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE."
LAST NIGHT’S DEBATE MAKES DUMB
AND DUMBER LOOK LIKE CITIZEN
KANE.
SOME CALL IT A DISASTER.
OTHERS A TRAIN WRECK.
EVEN THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF
DUMPSTER FIRES WEIGHED IN.
"PLEASE NOT MENTION DUMPSTER
FIRES IN THE SAME DEBATE.
HOW BAD WAS IT?
THIS BAD.
>> [CROSSTALK]
>> IF YOU GET NOMINATED, WE’LL
BE RELITIGATING THIS ALL YEAR.
>> FIRST OF ALL...
>> I THINK WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT -- IT TAKES TWO HOURS TO
DO THE MATH.
>> WHY AM I STOPPING?
NO ONE ELSE STOPS.
>> IF YOU COULD ALTER THE RULES
OF THE DEBATE, THANK YOU.
>> SENATOR SANDERS?
>> YOU ARE THE MODERATORS.
IS IT MY TURN?
>> IF YOU WOULD ALL, PLEASE...
>> Greg: I’M SEEING MORE ORDER
IN A PRISON RIOT.
THE CONSTANT OVER AND UNDER
TALKING CREATED AN APT METAPHOR
FOR THE DAMS, A DAY CARE CENTER
WITH NO SUPERVISION AND NO
DIAPERS.
INTERIM PARTY DEBATES REQUIRE
INFIGHTING, BUT ARE THEY IN THE
SAME PARTY, REALLY?
THEY WERE DIFFERENT SPECIES
EXCHANGING BATTLE CRIES.
THE MOST CAPABLE CANDIDATE COULD
BARELY TELL A JOKE.
>> I’M SAD THAT ALL OF MY FELLOW
CONTESTANTS APPEAR, I GUESS
WOULD BE THE RIGHT WORD FOR IT,
GIVEN THAT NOBODY PAYS ATTENTION
TO THE CLOCK, I’M SURPRISED THEY
SHOW UP BECAUSE I WOULD’VE
THOUGHT AFTER I DID SUCH A
GOOD JOB IN BEATING THEM LAST
WEEK THAT THEY’D BE A LITTLE BIT
AFRAID TO DO THAT.
>> Greg: NOT AS SAD AS
WATCHING HIM APOLOGIZE TO A
LEFTIST FOR CURBING CRIME
BECAUSE ONCE YOU DO THAT THEY
SMELL BLOOD.
AND THEN THERE IS NO
FORGIVENESS, ONLY PUNISHMENT
UNLESS THEY ARE GOOD ACTUAL
CRIMINAL.
THOSE ARE THE BIG PROBLEMS.
THAT WASN’T A DEBATE.
IT WAS A LAUNCH PARTY ON THE
TITANIC.
LAST NIGHT YOU SAW THE
OPPOSITION TALKS A NETWORK WHERE
EVERY IDEA IS POSITIONED AS A
VERSUS B, MEN VERSUS WOMEN,
BLACK VERSUS WHITE, GAY VERSUS
STRAIGHT, UNITY MEANS OPPRESSION
WHICH IS DRIVEN BY BIGOTRY FOR
THE IDEA OF FREE MARKETS AND
FREE MINDS, THEY SHOUT ABOUT HOW
BAD EVERYTHING IS COMING EVEN
WHEN THINGS ARE GREAT.
BUT THINGS AREN’T GREAT FOR
EVERYONE, THEY’LL TELL YOU.
TRUE.
BUT YOUR DIVISIVE METHODS ONLY
MAKES THINGS WORSE FOR PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO DO BETTER AND WHO
ARE TRYING TO DO BETTER.
THAT’S THE OPPOSITIONAL MIND-SET
MIND-SET.
EVERY ANSWER ENDS WITH "OFF WITH
THEIR HEADS."
THE ONLY WAY YOU CAN DO BETTER
IS WHEN SOMEONE DOES WORSE.
THEY MANAGED TO BLITZ AS A
GLOBAL VIRUS BEAR THAT’S NOT A
MESSAGE, IT IS A VIRUS.
THEY ARE STUCK WITH IT.
KATIE, WHAT WERE YOUR FAVORITE
MOMENTS?
>> Katie: WHAT YOU SAW LAST
NIGHT -- A WEEK OUT FROM SUPER
TUESDAY, THIS WAS THE OVER
TALKING, NOT STICKING TO THE
RULES, WAS A PREVIEW OF DYING,
THRASHING CAMPAIGNS.
THIS WAS THE LAST STOP FOR
PEOPLE LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN,
AMY KLOBUCHAR, MAYOR PETE --
THEY ARE DONE AND IF THEY DON’T
GET ANY KIND OF BOOST OUT OF
THIS DEBATE AND AS WE’VE SEEN
HIM SEEN, DEBATE HAS NOT PAID
OFF IN TERMS OF SUPPORT FOR
OTHER PEOPLE.
I THOUGHT ELIZABETH WARREN HAD
THE WEIRDEST ATTACK OF THE NIGHT
WHEN SHE WENT AFTER
MAYOR BLOOMBERG AFTER ALLEGEDLY
TELLING A FEMALE EMPLOYEE FOR
KILLING HER BABY WHEN SHE WAS
PREGNANT, WHICH TOOK AWAY THE
LEFT ARGUMENT ON THE ABORTION
ISSUE.
ON ONE HAND, SHE SAYING THAT
ABORTION IS NOT KILLING, BUT
THEN SHE ACCUSES MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG OF TELLING AN EMPLOYEE
TO KILL HER BABY, WHICH I
THOUGHT DEMOCRATS WERE ABOUT
CHOICE -- IT’S A VERY WEIRD
THING FOR HER TO SAY.
CERTAINLY DIDN’T GET HER
ANYWHERE GOING TO SOUTH CAROLINA
ON SATURDAY.
>> Greg: THEY’VE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO BACK UP THAT CLAIM
ANYWAY.
JUAN?
WAS IT CBS’S FAULT OR THE  DEMS’
FAULT?
>> Juan: THIS WAS THE LAST TO
BE BEFORE SOUTH CAROLINA AND
SUPER TUESDAY, AS KATIE WAS
LAYING OUT COME OF THE LAST SHOT
TO MAKE THEIR CAGE BEFORE THE
BIG VOTE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE DESPERATE AND
THEY ARE HUNGRY AND THEY ARE
GOING TO CLAW.
THEY SHOULD’VE HAD BETTER GUARD
RAILS.
AT THIS TABLE, WE MAKE AN EFFORT
NOT TO OVER TALK BECAUSE THE
ARGUMENT GETS ANGRY FOR THE
AUDIENCE DOESN’T LIKE IT.
NOT ONLY LACKING IN DECORUM BUT
IN THE EFFECT OF THIS IF YOU ARE
TRYING TO DELIVER A MESSAGE.
THAT’S A MISTAKE.
MAYBE YOU DON’T NEED MODERATORS
IN SOME CASES.
LINCOLN-DOUGLAS DID NOT HAVE A
MODERATOR.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN VERY CLEAR ABOUT
LENGTHS, TIMES, BABY BELLS AND
WHISTLES
FOX HAS DONE IT AND HAD TO DO IT
IN 2016 WITH THE REPUBLICANS.
>> Jesse: MAYBE ELECTRIC
COLLARS...
I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU, THIS IS
LIKE WATCHING PEOPLE FIGHT OVER
WHAT KIND OF COUGH AND THEY
WOULD BURIED IN.
I WENT AND LOOKED AT THE BIG
HIGHLIGHTS FROM OTHER CYCLES TO
SEE WHAT I WAS MISSING AND
RUBIO, CRUZ, CHRISTIE, ROB D,
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE WOULD
DECIMATE ANY ONE OF THESE PEOPLE
THAT WE SAW LAST LEG.
IMAGINE WHAT TRUMP WOULD DO.
BERNIE SANDERS DOES NOT EVEN WIN
THE DEBATE.
HE JUST GETS TO THE LEFT OF
EVERY BODY AND PALS THE PODIUM.
HE HAS NO DEPTH OF KNOWLEDGE IN
HIS OWN PROPOSALS.
EVERYTHING IS SO THIN, PUNCHING
ONE TIME AND HE JUST SAYS
BILLIONAIRE!
THAT’S NOT GOING TO LAST.
HE’S GOING GET EATEN ALIVE
EVENTUALLY.
MIKE BLOOMBERG HAS NO
PERSONALITY.
HE JUST MEMORIZES TALKING POINTS
AND DELIVERS THEM LIKE A ROBOT.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN ANYBODY SO
RICH AND SUCCESSFUL BOMB LIKE
THAT BEFORE.
BE A BOSS!
THEN THERE IS A BIDEN WHO I
GUESS WAS MORE VIGOROUS BUT HE
DIDN’T HAVE ANY MACHO MOMENTS
BUT HE GETS RUN OVER BY A
MODERATOR.
IT’S THE MOST PATHETIC THING
I’VE EVER SEEN.
WARREN IS THE MOST ANNOYING
PERSON I THINK I’VE EVER SEEN ON
TELEVISION.
SHE’S INTOLERABLE.
I HAVE A VERY HIGH TOLERANCE
LEVEL.
ALL SHE SAYS IS, WE NEED, WE
NEED, WE NEED.
IT’S LIKE A VERBAL TECH THAT
DOESN’T STOP.
SHE’S NOT RUNNING FOR SECOND
PLACE, BERNIE’S ATTACK DOG,
PLAYED THE GENDER CARD ON HIM,
WENT OUT IN FLAMES, NOW SHE’S
JUST CARRYING HIS WATER.
PETE IS THE BEST OF EVERYBODY
BUT HE’S A BOY.
HE LOOKS LIKE A CHILD OUT THERE.
FRAMES AND ISSUE VERY CONCISELY
BUT HE DOESN’T EVER PUNCH ABOVE
HIS WEIGHT CLASS.
EVERY TIME HE TRIES TO HIT ONE
OF THE BIG DOGS COME HE GETS
TALKED OVER.
AMY LOST HER SENSE OF HUMOR.
WHERE DID THAT GO?
AND STEYER A PASSIONATE GUY BUT
HE’S LIKE A LIZARD.
SO HARD TO LOOK LIKE.
HARD TO TAKE HIM SERIOUSLY.
>> Juan: I THINK YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN.
>> Dana: READ THAT ON THE
CANDIDATES...
>> Juan: I THINK A LOT OF THE
THE THING THAT REALLY STRUCK ME
GOING BACK TO SOMETHING THAT
KATIE SAID, LIKE THE THING ABOUT
THE BABY -- BY THE WAY,
BLOOMBERG SAID IT WASN’T FALSE,
SAID I DIDN’T SAY THAT.
REMEMBER, WHAT WOULD’VE BEEN
FALSE IS TO SAY THAT HER BEING
FIRED FROM THE SCHOOL BECAUSE
SHE SAID SHE WAS PREGNANT --
THIS WAS ELIZABETH WARREN, NEVER
SAID THAT WAS WRONG.
THE FACT SHE’S THROWN OUT THERE
IS SO DAMAGING FOR MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG.
THE WHOLE RACIST THING ABOUT THE
GUNS AND SANDERS...
>> Jesse: HE’S GETTING PRETTY
ANNIHILATED OUT THERE.
>> Juan: I THINK HE’S PRETTY
GOOD IN THIS CONTEST.
>> Jesse: NOT BY DEBATING.
I THINK HIS WHOLE SUCCESS IS BY
ADS.
>> Juan: BERNIE?
>> Jesse: NO.
>> Greg: THE WEIRDEST AND MOST
REAL THING, I’VE NEVER SEEN A
CAMPAIGN AD DURING THE DEBATE.
DID YOU SEE THAT?
ANYWAY, BLOOMBERG HAD AN AD AT
THE DEBATE.
WHY DON’T THEY ALL DO THAT?
>> Dana: THEY DON’T HAVE THE
MONEY.
>> Greg: DOESN’T THIS MAKE
TRUMP LOOK BETTER WHEN YOU SEE
ALL OF THIS?
THE JUAN’S POINT, IT’S TROOPER
THEY’VE GOT TO FIGHT BUT IT
MAKES THEM LOOK SMALLER.
>> Dana: THEY
I THINKINCUMBENT PRESIDENTS HAVE
A FRIEND OFIN TEACHES AT A
MAJOR LEASTASD ME TO TAKE
TO, THE MAN HAS HOUSE AND THE
SENATE OTHER,AND SO SUPERFICIAL.
THERE IS NO ACTUAL DEBATE ABOUT
OKAY, WHAT WOULD YOU ACTUALLY
DO?
WHAT WITH THE ISSUES THAT YOU
WOULD DEAL WITH?
BUT BIDEN GOT VERY GOOD NEWS
TODAY WITH THE ENDORSEMENT FROM
JIM CLYBURN AND THE PALMETTO
STATE POLL WHICH WAS THE MOST
ACCURATE ONE FOR SOUTH CAROLINA
IN 2016 WHICH SAID BIDEN IS UP
35 THE NEXT ONE IS STEYER AT 17
AND BERNIE AT 13.
BIDEN COULD WIN SOUTH CAROLINA,
DOESN’T HAVE A LOT OF MONEY TO
COMPETE AND SUPER TUESDAY.
>> Juan: I’VE GOT TO TELL YOU.